you know what never gets old blatant
irreverence violence and vulgarity with
costumed superheroes and supervillains
never never ever kick ass too so kick
ass 2 is a sequel to kick ass if you
haven't seen kick ass yet you should
watch kick ass and then kick ass - we
have kick ass and hit girl they've made
their mark on the world you know they've
started a revolution a lot more costume
superheroes are showing up and McLovin
'he's really pissed off at kick-ass well
spoiler alert for kick-ass 1 you've
wasted his dad so now Mick Lovins a new
villain called the it is
his name I love how I apologetically
right here was like hey it's his name I
didn't make it up because I'd never ever
cuss and on my show or whatever so
now kick-ass has to team up with these
other superheroes led by Colonel stars
and stripes he's played by Jim Carrey
who's awesome I know Jim Carrey was like
hey I don't like this movie anymore cuz
it's on the pacifist now but Jim Carrey
be proud your role in this movie was
awesome I'm not gonna say it was
kick-ass because that shit's just it's
too easy saying things in kick-ass
movies kick-ass - that is so 2010 we
don't do that anymore oh yeah he kicked
ass already like his 2000 done so the
getting an army together
to get revenge on kick-ass and kick ass
and his new crew they're cleaning up the
streets all the while hit girls like you
know what I got to be a normal kid I'm
not hit girl anymore so she's trying to
balance high school and she's trying to
be normal but just really not working
out for her I actually like that I mean
I know that's really risky hit girls
like the coolest thing about the
kick-ass movies and for most of this
movie she's not actually in the hit girl
costume she's trying to balance high
school usually I'd be like dumb but it
actually wasn't bad it was interesting
because her as a person she's
interesting I actually really like
kick-ass - a lot I don't think you can
love kick-ass one and then just hate
kick-ass - you can tell it is a
different director because of the
blatant overuse of shaky-cam
I gripe about shaky cam action sequences
a lot in my movie reviews I get that but
that's because directors overuse shaky
cam action sequences what's up with that
shaky cam is not cool it was never
cool a couple of directors can pull it
off the rest of you stop doing it
remember the days when an action
sequence was properly framed up and you
can just enjoy it I miss those days
there were a couple of really cool
fights in the movie that you could see
coolest fights in the movie are the ones
without shaky cam and the fact that
they're even in the movie shows that the
director knows how to do it so why why
that why the mixed signals here
although kick-ass 2 was really awesome
this movie has more than a few really
good moments there's a scene where the
visiting this dude he's -
dude from Game of Thrones you know that
one guy who hangs out with khaleesies
all I guess crazy it's true I want to
bang the out of you yeah that dude
that that moment is actually really good
as movie had a lot of enjoyment in it
it's really cool I suggest you if you're
a fan of kick-ass one set aside the fact
that it has a different director don't
be petty about that go into
kick-ass to have a good time because
you're going to because I would buy
kick-ass 2 on blu-ray
that's right buy it on blu-ray right
next to my kick-ass one and all will be
right with the world so if you were to
be a superhero what superhero would you
be like really I'm not saying like
someone who flies and looks through
walls and has invisibility that's just
not real now your real superhero name
and gimmick if you got it whatever it
would be comment below let me know me I
can't tell you because I don't have
anonymity like you I say my superhero
name and then when I'm out there doing
my thing and I show up on the news
people will be like oh yeah that's
Jeremy Jones on YouTube wouldn't work
you understand you understand and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more